[Musik]
jubel bei den grünen in baden
württemberg bleibt die partei von
ministerpräsident kretschmann weit vorne
in rheinland pfalz kann
spd-ministerpräsidentin drei jahre
weiterregieren reisen ohne auflagen die
balearen sind kein corona risikogebiet
mehr in deutschland steigt die inzidenz
weiter schule öffnungen geraten
zunehmend in die kritik
und auf zu olympia mit einem sieg gegen
algerien qualifizieren sich die
deutschen handballer für tokio
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers
ich freue mich dass sie bei uns sind
norbert lehmann kümmert sich nachher in
der sendung um den sport ein stück von
mir
dieser sonntag ist der start ins
superwahljahr für deutschland in eines
das es so noch nie gab
wegen der pandemie gibt es eine
rekordzahl von brief wählerinnen und
wählern bei den landtagswahlen in
baden-württemberg und rheinland-pfalz
heute nach den ersten hochrechnungen
sieht es so aus als können
ministerpräsidentin malu dreyer in mainz
und ministerpräsident winfried
kretschmann in stuttgart ihre ämter
behalten
spd und grüne würden danach jeweils
stärkste parteien interessant werden die
künftigen koalition und für den ganz
aktuellen stand gehen wir jetzt live ins
zdf wahlstudio zu matthias fornoff
gelang matthias grünert christian guten
abend es gibt frische zahlen zu baden
württemberg das ist die hochrechnung von
19 uhr
die schauen wir uns jetzt mal an demnach
kommen die grünen auf 30,9 prozent mit
leichten zugewinnen die cdu
das sind die gewinne und verluste sehen
sie unterhalb der balken die cdu 22,9
die afd 12,5 die spd 10,7 die fdp 11,5
die linke 3,6 prozent wäre also wie
bisher immer nicht in mainz eine
stuttgarter vertreten
die freien wähler 3 prozent und jetzt
schauen wir auf die sitze im stuttgarter
landtag die absolute mehrheit liegt bei
76 da sind überhang und
ausgleichsmandaten stand jetzt schon
eingerechnet 151 sitze insgesamt die
grünen kämen auf 53 die cdu auf 39 afd
21 spd 18 und die fdp 20 sitze und jetzt
müssen wir gucken wer erreicht diese
absolute mehrheit von 76 in welcher
koalition
grüne und cdu die derzeit regieren
schaffen das deutlich 92 sitze grüne mit
der spd schaffen es nicht da fehlen fünf
sitze grüne und fdp
da fehlen vier sitze grüne spd und fdp
das dreierbündnis das wäre die
alternative nach den zahlen im moment
die absolute mehrheit 76 auch geschafft
schauen wir nach rheinland pfalz
die hochrechnung von 19 uhr 2 die spd
34,2 prozent auch hier gewinne zu 2016
und verluste unterhalb der balken cdu
26,5 prozent
afg 9,8 fdp 6,0 grüne 8,5 linke 2,6 auch
nicht im landtag vertreten die freien
wähler aber mit 5,8 prozent was heißt
das in der sitzverteilung im mainzer
landtag die absolute mehrheit liegt bei
51 101 sitze gibt es über hans
ausgleichsmandaten gab es noch nie die
spd 38 sitze die cdu 30
die afg 11 die fdp 7 die grünen 9 und
die freien wähler hätten sechs sitze die
absolute mehrheit noch mal 51 sitze die
braucht man zum regieren und wir schauen
mal was demnach möglich wäre
das dreierbündnis das derzeit regiert
spd grüne fdp käme drüber über die 51
mit 54 das reicht also für rot grün
würde es nicht reichen für die große
koalition würde es deutlich reichen für
eine koalition spd grüne und freie
wähler falls das politisch überhaupt
eine option ist würde es auch reichen
und auch dass die frage ob es
realistisch ist ich saß aber trotzdem
mal cdu grüne fdp 46 das würde ebenfalls
nicht reichen in beiden ländern haben
wir eine wahlbeteiligung von etwa 65
prozent ziemlich durchschnittlich für
landtagswahlen und etwas schwächer als
vor fünf jahren
da aber war die flüchtlings diskussion
im mittelpunkt und hat sehr polarisiert
matthias du hast die wahlbeteiligung
schon angesprochen jetzt gab es ja heute
einen enorm hohen anteil von
briefwählerinnen und briefwähler
wie wirkt der sich denn auf die
genauigkeit dieser hochrechnungen aus
also anders gefragt sind dann noch
überraschungen möglich
naja soviel briefwahl war noch nie das
kann man klar sagen und das hat
rückwirkungen für die meinungsforscher
es macht ihnen das geschäft schlichtweg
schwerer daten kommen später es dauert
länger auszuzählen in den wahllokalen
das hat aber auch mit abstandsregeln zu
tun und deshalb müssen wir im moment
sagen mal ein bisschen vorsichtig muss
man mit den zahlen umgehen unsere
forschungsgruppe wahlen rechnet damit
dass mit diesen frühen zahlen am abend
dass es größere abweichungen pro partei
geben könnte
als wir das normalerweise sehen im
moment vielen dank matthias fornoff und
dann schauen wir traditionell in dieser
19 uhr sendung am wahlsonntag auf die
reaktionen der spitzenleute in beiden
ländern und beginnen in baden
württemberg mit bettina schausten in
stuttgart halle bettina ja so ist es
vielen dank christian wir sind hier im
großen rund versammelt das volk den
abstandsregeln die notwendig sind müssen
uns aber trotzdem knapp halten alle sind
gekommen und wir beginnen natürlich beim
wahlsieger in baden württemberg winfried
kretschmann zum zweiten mal
wiedergewählt als ministerpräsident des
landes und die meist gestellte frage an
sie ist heute abend natürlich wie machen
sie jetzt weiter geht es weiter mit
grünen schwarz sie haben da durchaus
sympathien erkennen lassen im vorfeld
oder geht von baden württemberg von
kretschmann ein ampelsignal aus in
dieses war 21 also erstmal freue ich
mich natürlich dass wir wieder bestätigt
worden sind als stärkste politische
kraft in baden württemberg daraus leidig
in der tat den auftrag ab eine neue
regierung zu bilden und wie es der
brauch ist werde ich dazu gespräche
führen mit den demokratischen parteien
im landtag und damit keine spekulation
entstehen mache ich es einfach in der
reihe der größe in der reihenfolge und
dann wird man sehen was sich daraus
ergibt also keine vorfestlegung
susanne eisenmann die cdu in baden
württemberg hat das schlechteste
ergebnis in ihrer geschichte eingefahren
welche konsequenzen ziehen sie daraus
muss die partei personell neu
aufgestellt werden
also zunächst mal gratuliere ich wie ein
freak red mit den grünen zu diesem
hervorragenden wahlerfolg und es ist
auch deutlich geworden
das muss man sagen dass die
baden-württemberger winfried kretschmann
weiterhin als ministerpräsident haben
wollten das gehört einfach zur wahrheit
und zu und die cdu hatte ein
enttäuschendes ergebnis ein desaströses
ergebnis das muss man absolute auch das
ehrlich sagen dass ich natürlich
verantwortung übernehme aber die cdu
wird intern und in aller offenheit aber
auch aufarbeiten
warum sie seit zehn jahren schritt für
schritt an zustimmung in
baden württemberg verliert auch das
gehört natürlich dazu perspektive
aufzuarbeiten und neue perspektiven sich
zu erarbeiten und ansonsten natürlich
ist die cdu gesprächsbereit aber
zunächst mal muss man natürlich sich
auch mit den konsequenzen aus dem
heutigen wahlergebnis befassen
andreas stoch ist der
spd-spitzenkandidat herrscht oft das ist
ein miserables ergebnis für die spd das
schlechteste auch sie leiten daraus
trotzdem ab mitzuregieren haben
wahrscheinlich gerade gehört und warten
jetzt auf die gespräche die wähler sehen
das offenbar nicht so einfach schausten
das ist sicherlich nicht das ergebnis
das ich mir für meine spd gewünscht habe
aber man muss eben auch sagen die
wählerinnen und wähler haben gerade wenn
es in dem politischen feld mitte links
winfried kretschmann den grünen den
vorzug gegeben das war bei der letzten
wahl schon so dass eine starke
verschiebung innerhalb dieses lagers
grad in richtung der grünen ich möchte
auch winfried kretschmann ganz herzlich
gratulieren zu seinem wahlerfolg ist der
wahlsieger und hat den auftrag die neue
regierung zu bilden aber wir haben von
anfang an gesagt diese regierung der
letzten fünf jahre aus grünen und cdu
hat wichtige themen nicht angepackt
nicht vorangebracht und wir haben immer
gesagt wir brauchen in baden württemberg
nicht wegen der spd sondern wegen der
menschen in diesem land eine neue
regierung die die wichtigen themen
anpackt in wohnungsbau die
bildungsgerechtigkeit und dafür brauchst
glaube ich eine neue regierung und wenn
die spd dort sozialdemokratische politik
einbringen kann dann stehen für diese
gespräche natürlich offen fast schon
eine bewerbungsrede dankeschön hans
ulrich rülke von der fdp die fdp konnte
zulegen wie wollen sie jetzt den
ministerpräsidenten von einer ampel
überzeugen nun zunächst mal gratuliere
ich auch winfried kretschmann zu diesem
wahlerfolg
es ist klar geworden die menschen wollen
dass er weiter das amt des
ministerpräsidenten in baden württemberg
ausfüllt kann aber sagen dass wir als
fdp glaube ich der gewinner dieser wahl
sind wir haben am meisten stimmen
zugelegt wir haben offensichtlich das
beste ergebnis in baden-württemberg
erzielt seit 1968 und ich habe im
wahlkampf immer deutlich gemacht die fdp
strebt eine regierungsbeteiligung an
offensichtlich ist es so dass die
menschen
land baden württemberg das auch wünschen
es liegt jetzt bei ministerpräsident
kretschmann er hat ja gesagt er möchte
mit den demokratischen parteien
sondieren
der kollege teurer mein
landesvorsitzender nicht werden wenn
dieses angebot kommt unseren
spitzengremien der landesvorstand und
der neu gewählten fraktion empfehlen
dieses angebot anzunehmen und wir werden
konstruktive gespräche führen mit dem
ziel für baden württemberg eine gute und
stabile regierung zu bilden
während gögele spitzenkandidat der afg
die afg konnte nicht nennenswert von dem
corona frust vieler menschen profitieren
liegt es an ihrem tief tief
zerstrittenen landesverband nein mit
sicherheit nicht erlauben sie mir auch
herrn kretschmann zu seinem wahlsieg zu
gratulieren ganz persönlicher erfolg von
herrn kretschmann sicher nicht so sehr
von der politik der grünen
wir haben hier in eine gesundheitskrise
sie haben wir sicherlich die erfahrung
gemacht dass menschen sich hinter den
handelnden versammeln hinter den
regierenden weil nur die agieren können
und jetzt warten wir es mal ab wir haben
ein super wahljahr vor uns und die
schäden der politik die aus unserer
sicht zum teil falsch angesetzt ist die
werden sich im laufe des jahres zeigen
und da wollen wir mal sehen wie die
ergebnisse dann aussehen
wir sind mit unserem ergebnis zufrieden
wir haben zwar etwas verloren aber wir
dürfen nicht vergessen 20 16
der andere situation das war der
höhepunkt der flüchtlingskrise da hat
sich auch von diesem protest kfd im
besonderen profitiert das war in diesem
wahlkampf sicher nicht das thema und
corona ich kein wahlkampfthema da haben
sich alle der mit verabredet wenn man
davon spricht dass er mit den
demokratischen parteien gespräche führen
wird dann zielt ja wieder bewusst auf
hunderttausenden von wähler so wenn ich
den wahlkampf nicht fortsetzen bitten um
verständnis dafür also baden württemberg
grüner wahlerfolg und offen in welcher
koalition ist weiter geht damit zurück
nach mainz zu christian sievers mit den
vielen dank nach stuttgart und wir gehen
jetzt in dieser sendung gleich weiter
über nach rheinland pfalz wo ebenfalls
die spitzenrunde zusammensteht live in
mainz bei susanne gelhard guten namen zu
seiner guten damen sind danke christian
hier stehen hier in unserem wahlstudio
vor dem landtag von rheinland-pfalz alle
spitzenkandidaten und spitzenkandidaten
sind da frau dreyer sie als
ministerpräsidentin
spd-spitzenkandidatin lagen ursprünglich
hinter der die cdu haben auf den letzten
metern aufgeholt woran hat es gelegen
ich bin ein ganz glücklicher mensch
heute und ich will einfach mal danke
schön sagen an die bürger an die
bürgerinnen die und sie vertrauen wieder
geschenkt haben und ich will ihnen auch
zugleich versichern dass wieder
ministerpräsidentin für alle bürger und
bürgerinnen sein möchte und ich bin
natürlich auch froh dass meine partei
wirklich so gekämpft hat und wir es
schaffen konnten unser wahlziel zu
erreichen nämlich stärkste partei zu
werden in rheinland pfalz und das mit
großem abstand und ich will auch noch
sein vater hat es war ein sehr fairer
wahlkampf vielleicht an alle mitbewerber
auch das möchte ich unbedingt sagen es
hat wirklich spaß gemacht hier wahlkampf
zu machen klar und es ist so dass wir
fünf jahre gut zusammen regiert haben
also auch in asien glückwunsch an die
kolleginnen und das haben uns jetzt die
bürger und bürgerinnen eben auch noch
mal das vertrauen dazu geschenkt dass
wir weitermachen können
darüber bin ich sehr glücklich es war
ein großer wunsch von mir dass ich auch
weiterhin mit meiner partei regierung
bilden darf und weiterhin in diesem land
tatsächlich regierungschefin sein kann
christian baldauf von der cdu es ist
noch nicht lange her da haben sie
geführt wir haben es vorhin gehört jetzt
stehen sie mit leeren händen da keines
ihrer wahlziele haben sie erreicht was
es passiert das ist ein sehr bitterer
abend aber das möchte ich auch sagen vor
drei jahren glück wunsch wir hatten eine
situation die wir sehr genau analysieren
müssen es war ein von corona geprägter
wahlkampf der natürlich auch eine oben
die präsenz der regierenden mit sich
gebracht hat er gezeigt hat dass man
themen die das land betreffen nicht so
einfach spielen kann wie man das
sich so vorgestellt hatte trotzdem lange
sich vor kurzem auch schon das ist
richtig und dann braucht man natürlich
auch eine geschlossene
mannschaftsleistung auf allen ebenen
damit das auch funktioniert das heißt
berlin ist schon das will ich nicht
sagen das würde ich auch nicht so
beschreiben wollen wir werden das jetzt
sauber analysieren ist auch nicht
einfach ein spruch wer mich kennt weiß
wir müssen genau schauen wo sind die
unterschiedlichen punkte die dazu
geführt haben ja vor vier wochen lagen
wir vorne und das müssen wir natürlich
ergründen warum es jetzt nicht mehr so
ist eine spiegel ist spitzenkandidatin
der grünen
sie sind besser als das letzte mal nicht
so stark wie erhofft es wird
wahrscheinlich auch um eine neuauflage
der ampel geben
da sind sie dann wahrscheinlich königin
macherin ja also zunächst mal herzlichen
glückwunsch an nach baden württemberg an
den freed kretschmann ich glaube das ist
für uns grüne auch ein toller auftakt in
einem superwahljahr
und was die situation hier in rheinland
pfalz angeht ja wir haben uns als grüne
stark verbessert darüber freuen wir uns
natürlich und für uns ist das auch ein
klarer regierungsauftrag für
konsequenten klimaschutz von der kfd die
großen parteien haben verloren vor allem
die cdu aber auch ein paar punkte bei
der spd trotzdem haben sie davon nicht
profitieren können im gegenteil auch sie
haben prozentpunkte verloren
warum sind sie für 90 prozent der
menschen keine alternative na ja die
frage könnten sie in anderen parteien
aufstellen mit jeweils die differenz zu
100 prozent bilden weil man bei ihnen
war es so dass wir 2016 natürlich
außerordentlich günstige
rahmenbedingungen hatten die waren
diesmal deutlich schlechter erinnere
etwa an die instrumentalisierung des
verfassungsschutzes gegen uns dann aber
auch an die korinther situation wo wir
es sehr schwierig hatten mit unseren
botschaften durchzudringen wir waren bei
weitem nicht in den medien so präsent
wie die anderen parteien und das erklärt
warum wir zwar ein gutes aber nicht ganz
das ergebnis vom letzten mal erreicht
susanne frau schmidt sie sind das
schlusslicht in der ampel und trotz
ihres hauptthemas wirtschaft das ja sehr
wichtig ist in corona zeiten konnten sie
nicht mehr punkten warum ich sehe uns
nicht als schlusslicht wir haben unser
ergebnis stabil gehalten
wir schauen mal die weiteren ergebnisse
des abends ab und entscheidend ist man
dass man den regierungsverantwortung
dann auch weiter akzente setzt und
deswegen möchten wir gerne weiter tun
viele herausforderungen stehen vor uns
die wirtschaft ist von enormen
herausforderungen betroffen und da gilt
es auch zukunftsthemen zu begleiten und
das würden wir auch gerne in
regierungsverantwortung weiter tun
auch im streit von den freien wählern im
moment sieht es so aus dass sie drin
sind mit gut über 5% man muss noch ein
bisschen aufpassen aber wenn es so
bleibt zum ersten mal hier im landtag
rheinland-pfalz sind sie nur zufrieden
oder sogar ein bisschen mehr auf
koalitions will ich nun die
zufriedenheit ist sehr groß wir haben
unser ziel erreicht wir haben die fünf
prozent hürde genommen
und damit sind wir im reinen feld
zwischen landtag und die vielen freien
wählergruppen in rheinland-pfalz haben
einen parlamentarischen arm im reinen
feld zwischen landtag und das macht
einen ja sehr zufrieden und dann nochmal
die schlussfrage an frau dreyer sie sind
die stärkste kraft sie werden jetzt
koalitionsgespräche führen
gibt es eine neuauflage der ampel wir
müssen natürlich auch den abend abwarten
aber ich bin ganz zuversichtlich und ich
habe mich immer sehr sehr klar
ausgedrückt die spd strebt anschlags
partei zu werden und die ampel koalition
fortzusetzen
und wenn der abend so weiter geht wäre
das natürlich unsere erste wahl ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich dass wir auch
gemeinsam uns wieder verständigen können
so das waren jetzt die
spitzenkandidatinnen und
spitzenkandidaten aus rheinland pfalz
und damit zurück zu dir christian vielen
dank susanne natürlich guckt ganz
deutschland auf die wahl in den beiden
ländern besonders die bundespolitik hier
ist ja immer noch nicht klar wer
kanzlerkandidat der union werden soll
und gleichzeitig könnten sich neue macht
perspektiven eröffnen für grüne und spd
reaktionen aus berlin jetzt natürlich
ist winfried kretschmann eine
herausragende politische persönlichkeit
aber er hat im wahlkampf deutlich die
grünen themen nach vorne gestellt
es war ein gemeinsamer wahlkampf und
winfried kretschmann ist grüner durch
und durch also ohne seine herausragende
person schmälern zu wollen nein das ist
ein großer grüner wahlsieg
es ist heute ein sehr sehr guter tag für
die spd wir gratulieren malu dreyer zu
diesem großartigen wahlsieg seas
stärkste partei in rheinland pfalz zum
dritten mal und hat damit einen
großartigen walzik eingefahrenes in
aller klarheit zu sagen das ist heute
kein guter wahlabend für die cdu
wir hätten uns bei den landtagswahlen in
baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz
andere werden uns bessere ergebnisse
gewünscht
die freien demokraten freuen sich über
einen starken aufschlag in das richtige
wahl jahr 2021
es war ein schwieriger wahlkampf im
wahlkampf haben die regierungen von bund
und ländern die kommunikation dominiert
es ist ein wahlkampf gewesen der uns
eigentlich nicht gemäß sollen wir sehr
team online gemacht haben und wer unsere
wahlkämpfe kennt weiß dass wir für volle
hallen sorgen und dass da auch sehr gute
stimmung immer zustande kommt wir haben
unser ziel in den landtag einzuziehen in
beide landtage einzuziehen verpasst wir
hätten uns deutlich mehr gewünscht
natürlich sind die ergebnisse auch
angesichts der umfragen im vorfeld nicht
ganz überraschend aber trotzdem hatten
wir natürlich gehofft deutlich besser
abzuschneiden beiden ländern stimmen aus
der bundespolitik
es wird noch länger ausgezählt diesem
wahlabend wir informieren sie natürlich
weiter gleich wieder im zdf wahlstudio
und in unserer zdf heute app sind die
wahl natürlich auch ganz oben jetzt aber
erstmal weitere wichtige nachrichten von
diesem sonntag nach den ausschreitungen
bei protesten von selbsternannten
querdenkern in dresden fordern grüne und
linke im landtag eine politische
aufarbeitung des ganzen
zum wiederholten mal sei das fatale bild
entstanden dass der staat vor
gewaltbereiten zurückweichen
etwa 1000 menschen hatten gestern trotz
eines gerichtlichen verbots in der
innenstadt gegen die korona maßnahmen
protestiert die stimmung teils sehr
aggressiv laut polizei wurden 12 beamte
bei auseinandersetzungen verletzt
und dann gucken wir jetzt auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen in deutschland
die steigen laut robert koch institut
weiter deutlich an das lka meldet zehn
1790 neue infekt
und innerhalb eines tages das sind 2687
mehr als vor einer woche
70 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus die bundesweite inzidenz
steigt auf 79 ein klarer trend bei den
neuinfektionen also der
gesundheitsexperte der spd karl
lauterbach fordert deshalb alle schulen
bis ostern erst mal wieder zu schließen
auch die grundschulen ganz anderes bild
auf den balearen dort sinken die zahlen
und das heißt vor mallorca reisen wird
nicht mehr gewarnt thomas garcia strand
statt shutdown weites meer statt mehr
beschränkungen mallorca ist nicht mehr
risikogebiet heißt keine quarantäne
nach der rückkehr mehr lust hinzuweisen
mallorca eröffnet bayern schließt nach
etlichen landkreisen steigen auch in
größeren städten die instanzen die
zahlen drei tage in folge über 100 auch
in regensburg zieht man nun die
notbremse
nachts gilt eine ausgangssperre schulen
schließen wieder kritik ich verstehe
wenn eltern da unverständnis haben wir
haben baumärkte geöffnet aber die
schulen müssen wieder in distanz ich
glaube dass man für die schulen konzepte
entwickeln muss dass man unabhängig vom
incidents wert die kinder in die schule
schicken kann
ähnlich denkt auch nordrhein-westfalens
regierung notbremse schulen dicht nur
wenn sonst nichts mehr hilft der kreis
düren sident seit zwei wochen über 100
ist deshalb gezwungen weiterführende
schulen morgen wieder zu öffnen hätten
uns definitiv eine andere entscheidung
gewünscht haben das aber jetzt eben zu
akzeptieren und können jetzt nur auf
andere präventive maßnahmen setzen
impfen vor allem vielmehr will das auch
sachsen und zwar
18 ab mittwoch im vogtlandkreis die
inzidenz 295,6 problem auch dort
astrazeneca liefert weniger alles dauert
länger heute schon jede menge nachfragen
weil die leute keine termine mehr buchen
können mallorca hat geöffnet deutschland
ist insgesamt weit davon entfernt
welch ein kontrast und jetzt ist norbert
hier und liefert den sport bei
mit der guten nachricht für die
deutschen handball fans die
nationalmannschaft hat das ticket für
tokio gelöst im dritten olympia
qualifikationsspiel in berlin macht das
dhb team mit einem 34 26-sieg gegen
algerien alles klar
die dhb auswahl in weiß hat von beginn
an genug gelegenheiten das spiel gegen
außenseiter algerien zu kontrollieren
johannes dollar kann sich wiederholt
durchsetzen
andreas wolf hält auch siebenmeter und
bei den gästen sieht abderrahim barrier
nach einem schlag gegen philipp weber
rot doch die 17 14 führung zur pause ist
nicht wirklich beruhigend wie hat noch
die möglichkeit heute so blamieren und
gerade weil wir nicht so guten spielen
bekamen wer davon ab welcher leistung
natürlich also hin zu diversen saunen
und dann haben wir erst mit der zweiten
halbzeit so richtig umsetzen konnten das
wird dann doch noch der erwartet klaren
sieg fabian wiede trifft zum 34 zu 26
endstand deutschland kann in tokio dabei
sein
nach der enttäuschenden wm in ägypten
ist das minimalziel des jahres erstmal
erreicht zwei ergebnisse aus der
fußball-bundesliga leverkusen unterliegt
bielefeld mit 1 zu 2 die arminia nun auf
tabellenplatz 15 bayern bleibt sechster
und leipzig und frankfurt trennen sich
unentschieden eins zu eins die eintracht
weiter tabellenvierter r b als zweiter
jetzt mit vier punkten rückstand auf
tabellenführer bayern
maximilian schach mann ist wie schon im
vorjahr der sieger des radklassikers
paris nizza am schlusstag verletzte sich
der bis dahin führende slowenin primo
schoklitsch bei einem sturz und davon
profitierte schach mann er ist damit der
erste deutsche der diese
prestigeträchtige fernfahrt über acht
etappen gleich zweimal gewinnen konnte
das was von mir genau anschauen was
jetzt alle gemeinsam das wetter am
morgen wechselnd bewölkt mit vielen
schauern an den alpen auch viel schnee
dazu kräftiger wind und
höchsttemperaturen von zwei bis zehn
grad und auch in den nächsten tagen
unbeständig mit schnee regenschauern bis
ins flachland an den alpen viel
neuschnee
es wird kalt sowie alle von der heute 19
uhr danken herzlich für ihr interesse
hier im zdf geht es natürlich weiter
rund um die landtagswahlen und was
daraus folgt bei marietta slomka nachher
im heute journal